Extrem seltsame Objekte kreisen rasend schnell
um das zentrale Schwarze Loch in unserer Galaxie
Sagittarius A*.
Sie sehen aus wie Staubwolken, aber verhalten
sich ganz anders.
Jetzt hat eine Forschungsgruppe die Objekte
untersucht und vielleicht ihr Geheimnis gelüftet.
Clixoom Science & Fiction - Hier gibt es täglich
faszinierende Science-Videos, abonniert den
Kanal, nur dann verpasst ihr nichts - herzlich
willkommen!
Um endlich das Geheimnis der seltsamen Objekte
zu lüften analysierten sie den Daten der
vergangenen zwölf Jahre des OH-Suppressing
Infrared Imaging Sectrographs kurz OSIRIS
aus.
Dabei fanden die Wissenschaftlerinnen und
Wissenschaftler Objekte, die wie Staubwolken
anmuteten, aber ihr Verhalten im Gravitationsfeld
des Schwarzen Loches Sagittarius A* eher an
große Objekte, wie Sterne erinnerte.
Schon vorher wurden zwei dieser seltsamen
Objekte entdeckt, aber niemand konnte sich
einen Reim darauf machen.
Die Objekte G1 und G2.
G1 wurde 2004 entdeckt und G2 2012.
Mit der neuen Studie kamen aber drei neue
seltsame Objekte hinzu: G3, G4, G5.
Und sie alle haben diese seltsamen Eigenschaften.
Sie kreisen extrem nah und extrem schnell
um das Schwarze Loch.
Lange dachten Forscher und Forscherinnen,
dass es sich um Gaswolken handeln würde,
aber G1 und G2 hätten schon lange durch die
Gravbitation des Schwarzen Loches auseinandergerissen
werden müssen.
Das ist aber nicht geschehen.
Sie existieren weiter, was für Gaswolken
in der Nähe eines supermassereichen Schwarzen
Loches in dieser Nähe eigentlich nicht möglich
ist.
Mark Morris Forscher am UCLA Calactic Center
Obrits Initiative: „Wenn es sich um Gaswolken
handeln würde, hätten G1 und G2 nicht intakt
bleiben können.
Unsere Annahme ist, dass es sich bei G-Objekten
um aufgeblähte Sterne handelt — Sterne,
die so groß geworden sind, dass die Gezeitenkräfte,
die vom schwarzen Loch ausgehen, zwar Materie
abziehen können, wenn die Sterne nahe genug
dran sind, doch die einen stellaren Kern mit
genügend Masse haben, um intakt zu bleiben.“
Und die neuen Objekte G3, G4 und G5 verhalten
sich genauso.
Sie sind genauso aufgebläht, wie G1 und G2
und strahlen hohe Mengen an Energie aus.
Das Forschungsteam geht jetzt davon aus, dass
es sich bei den Objekten um kollidierte Stewrne
handelt.
Sie umkreisen sich und kollidieren schließlich.
Jetzt warten die Forscherinnen und Forscher
darauf, dass das Objekt G3 dem Schwarzen Loch
so nahe kommt, dass es , wenn es eine Gaswolken
wäre, auseinandergerissen werden würde.
In 20 Jahren wird es soweit sein und dann
soll G3 dabei beobachtet werden, wie es sich
verhält.
Dann erhofft sich das Team so mehr Erkenntnisse
über dies Objekte zu gewinnen, wenn sie direkt
das Verhalten am Schwarzen Loch beobachten
kann.
Was passiert in einem Schwarzen Loch?
Super Video von Doktor Whatson.
Draufklicken, anschauen und Doktor Whatson
abonnieren!
Bis dann, bleibt dran!